we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors if you're trying to quit
smoking or vaping check out lucy which
is a nicotine gum developed by caltech
scientists they'll ship it right to your
door and you can save 20
when you go to lucy.co and use coupon
code pacman
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
i want to start with something a little
different today you know we pointed out
that both during the trump
administration
and even after his election loss during
which he became
the lame duck president that he is now
as there were
many public scandals and much media
coverage of
some aspects of what donald trump was
doing there
continued to be republicans
doing things horrible things including
of course mitch mcconnell helping to
conf
confirm extremist judges but also
rolling back environmental regulations
which allow more pollution and all sorts
of stuff the point was
while this public-facing scandal-ridden
fiasco continued
below the surface the republicans were
doing things that are really horrible
well
we have now gotten a list of the things
that donald trump is going to try to
get done um hopefully without much
attention being paid to them
in the remaining seven weeks of his
presidency
and they are mostly outrageous and they
include listen to this
reinstating the death penalty via both
firing squad and the electric
chair before donald trump leaves office
and on the one hand you have much of the
developed world
which has rightly moved away from the
death penalty altogether and we've
talked about the death penalty
extensively before
whether you believe the death penalty
should be eliminated
because it is fiscally not conservative
it costs more actually in the united
states
than keeping somebody in prison for the
rest of their lives and we've talked
about why
whether it's because you believe in
small government and that the government
should not be killing
people whether it's because you believe
in the unfair way that the death penalty
is
disproportionately applied in certain
cases and not in others
anyway we've had we've adjudicated the
death penalty so many times
and many developed countries have
figured that out and have moved away
from the death penalty altogether
the united states meanwhile while some
states have moved away from the death
penalty
donald trump wants federally to rush in
the reinstatement of electric chair
and death by firing squad executions
for the death penalty um there are a
whole bunch of other proposals as well
which we are going to talk about now why
why would trump be trying to add new
ways that the government can kill people
via the death penalty why would they do
this one of the things that has slowed
down
executions over the last decade or more
in the united states
is that there are sometimes there is
sometimes
scant availability of lethal injection
drugs
so the idea is well let's move ahead
with some of these executions by adding
firing squad and electric chair
as options for how the federal
government would carry out these
executions now before we move forward i
think it's important to remind you that
most executions most most death penalty
executions in the united states
are done by states federal executions
are relatively rare
and so this would only change the
federal rules and to give you a num
an idea of how lopsided the numbers are
since 1977 there have been
fewer than 50 federal executions since
1977
okay but there have been around 1 500
execution by states so it's
extraordinarily lopsided
if trump does this it would only affect
federal executions but the point is
it would start increasing that number
more quickly i'm against the death
penalty
period um and i don't care how you're
doing it
um i am opposed to it if you're
interested in that topic it hasn't come
up on the show for
probably at least a year you can find
some of my archived clips on the youtube
channel
now other changes donald trump is trying
to rush through
in the waning days of his presidency he
wants a change at the usda
to allow faster chicken processing lines
in
slaughterhouses i don't know if you've
seen what a chicken processing line
looks like uh i think it's an
interesting thing to
uh to to understand as you all know i'm
not vegan or vegetarian but i do think
it's important to understand what
uh these mass processing facilities look
like and
it chicken processing is done
essentially on an assembly line
and the idea is to allow the assembly
line to move more quickly
and the reasons not to do that would be
it would increase the chance of errors
contamination possible errant cuts which
could spread bacteria as well as risk to
workers
but donald trump wants to allow that
donald trump wants to
make some additional rule changes that
would make it more
difficult for joe biden to quickly undo
some of the environmental restrictions
that donald trump eliminated
and trump also trying to push through a
regulation
that would exclude transgender
individuals
from federally funded homeless shelters
which is just
vile disgusting and unnecessarily cruel
trump would also loosen water saving
standards
on shower heads now that actually came
up at a bunch of trump rallies which we
covered
leading up to the election where trump
would be moan that if joe biden were to
win
you'd have trouble flushing toilets
you'd have trouble
getting good water pressure in the
shower trump at one point even wildly
claimed that if joe biden were to win
heating and cooling indoor heating and
cooling might be eliminated you might
have none of it under joe biden which
was a completely deranged claim to begin
with
and uh yeah just to get ready i have
stopped using heat i want to be ready
for when biden takes over but i'm hoping
that that one doesn't come to pass
that's a joke by the way imagine what
kind of a person you have to be
to say okay i've got seven weeks my last
and final seven weeks to impact
this country what can i do in this time
and the idea that comes to you is let me
expand the ways
in which the federal government is
allowed to kill people
that's a good use of my time when you
hear
trump wants to bring back firing squads
it almost sounds
like a headline from the onion a
satirical news headline
then you read the article and it is all
too real trump ignored the pandemic
since day one
but capital punishment and shower heads
are at the top of his important item
list to get done before leaving office
i would understand if the world takes a
while to forgive us
for this presidency so it turns out that
it's not just
outsiders realizing that donald trump's
legal team
of course including rudy giuliani are
making him look like an idiot we've now
learned that donald trump's inner circle
has also been advising donald trump hey
what rudy is doing is completely
embarrassing
the daily beast reports that members of
trump's inner circle
have been coming to him and saying sir
that's my ad-lib
sir he's making you look like an idiot
remember that just days prior
nbc reported trump was worried that his
legal team consisted of quote
fools that are making him look bad so it
does appear
that this is what donald trump is being
told but it's not stopping trump trump
continues tweeting about these people
he continues promoting these harebrained
voter fraud events they did one
yesterday
oh we covered a little bit of it live it
was rudy giuliani
and another trump attorney jenna ellis
in a room at a hotel
with some republican arizona lawmakers
bringing so-called witness after witness
to essentially say they
didn't like the way they were treated as
polling observers it was a bizarre
a dog and pony show but trump keeps
promoting it yesterday trump tweeted
trump legal team in arizona and
on oan now big stuff
enjoy this is not because people
aren't telling trump his legal team is
making him look ridiculous
trump is being told that we now know but
he continues to promote these events now
there's a couple possibilities
one possibility is trump believes that
these
lawyers are making him look stupid but
he doesn't care
because it either keeps his name in the
news uh or it lets him fundraise
half of the money remember half of the
money fund raised for these
recounts and all this nonsense half the
money goes to
paying off his campaign debt so maybe
trump thinks it's worth it
maybe trump hears the people coming to
him and saying these lawyers are making
you look stupid
and he doesn't believe it that's still a
possibility that trump just doesn't
believe that they're making him look
dumb
but look at the list now rudy giuliani
hosted that
ridiculous press conference at a
landscaping parking lot
in philadelphia weeks ago then rudy does
another press briefing in the basement
of a building somewhere in dc
that was the one where rudy's hair dye
made it look like he was bleeding out of
both ears
then rudy shows up at a hearing in
pennsylvania with republican state
lawmakers and spends
hours making unfounded claim after claim
about the election
but then trump calls into that one so he
couldn't have thought trump that is
trump couldn't have thought that one
made him look bad right i mean
he participated in it after all and then
yesterday trump also
called into the arizona i i don't even
like calling it a hearing
pr event that rudy giuliani did and
meanwhile there are increasingly calls
for rudy giuliani himself to have his
legal license revoked
for continuing to file these bogus legal
challenges
all of which are getting thrown out the
real way
that trump made himself look like an
idiot is hiring rudy in the first place
to represent him in court and i've
talked about this before there's a
big difference between a tv lawyer and a
courtroom lawyer
rudy giuliani for a while was trump's tv
lawyer meaning he went on tv
and he advocated for the president but
he did it in a way that you wouldn't
actually do in a courtroom
so on tv rudy says voter fraud and he
says they have all this evidence and
proof of all these different things
in a courtroom rudy is really not
equipped to handle these cases
and he has been unable to even
successfully
handle a single one of these cases and
the real mistake
that trump made was thinking that rudy
could actually be his courtroom lawyer
when he is in
way over his head a narcissist never
makes the connection though that
listen trump hired rudy if rudy is the
idiot
and rudy is making trump look like one
as well
trump also must be the idiot for for
hiring rudy to begin with
the way trump and narcissists work is
any good
is solely their own doing but any bad
is solely the fault of others period
full stop and to some degree remember
that donald trump sent out sean spicer
i i want to say it was the first day of
trump's administration maybe it was the
second but i thought it was within hours
of the inauguration
trump sent out spicer his first press
secretary
to lie about the size of trump's
inauguration crowd size
that made trump look like an idiot and
it's been four more years of the exact
same stuff so yes
rudy is making trump look like a fool
but trump hiring rudy confirmed to us
that trump was the fool before rudy
filed even a single one of these
completely bogus lawsuits
again today a voter fraud hearing in
michigan
unclear as of this moment whether rudy
giuliani is participating
but would not be at all surprised to see
him there let me know on twitter
what do you think is the point of these
hearings what are they trying to get out
of them is it just raising money to pay
off campaign debt
is it something else i'm deep hackman on
twitter let me know your thoughts
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience
20 off lucy is a company founded by
caltech scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020 it's time to throw
the cigarettes away and get rid of the
vape
and lucy can make it easier you'll find
a ton of excellent reviews online from
countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get 20
off when you use the coupon code pacman
and just
a quick disclaimer i'm required to give
these products contain
nicotine nicotine is an addictive
chemical
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that our primary funding source
every single month is revenue from
direct
memberships people like you you might
listen to
a podcast here or there watch a youtube
clip occasionally
catch a live stream who sign up
at joinpakman.com because of the virus
we've seen huge levels of cancellations
over the last two weeks people emailing
me as many as 25 a day saying david
i'm sorry i've been a member for years i
have to cut expenses i lost my job
i'm making half the money i was and i
totally get that
uh if you are in a position where a
couple of bucks a month is something
you can spare to support independent
media that you like
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code fresh start
which will save you 70 off of the cost
of a membership we cannot become numb
to violent attacks on our democracy we
can't do it
which is why we're down to seven weeks
but we must continue to cover
the things that donald trump is saying
and doing that are completely
anti-democratic now i know we've talked
before
we've become accustomed to this to some
degree
this has been normalized to some degree
because we've been dealing with it for
four years but we have to resist
the tendency to believe what's going on
is even remotely normal
this morning donald trump tweeted that a
governor overturned the results of the
election which trump lost
and then cancel i guess trump is
referring to
the upcoming senate runoffs it is not
100
clear what trump is demanding here but
what we can tell for sure
is that it's completely corrosive and
destructive to our democratic
institutions this morning in response to
a tweet about once again
dominion voting systems donald trump
tweeted quote
do something brian kemp you allowed your
state
to be scammed you must check signatures
and count signed envelopes against
ballots
then call off election it won't be
needed
we will all win so what i believe donald
trump is saying here
is maneuver the count of signatures
and envelopes which will lead to
trump winning georgia and i guess he
means
it will also lead to david perdue and
kelly loffler
both winning their senate races which
now are going to lead to runoffs
trump believes i guess if the votes are
counted the way
he wants them counted trump wins georgia
loffler wins georgia and purdue wins
georgia
and the runoffs are no longer needed
this is absolutely and totally insane
moments earlier
donald trump tweeted again incorrectly
and without evidence that
quote we won michigan by a lot
he of course did not win michigan he
lost michigan to joe biden
by about 150 000 votes he's just making
things up
seven minutes prior to that donald trump
tweeted quote
fake election results in nevada also
this is absolutely outrageous we can't
just
ignore it we have to actually resist
that this is normal in our minds for the
next seven weeks we've got to work hard
i i i'm you know as aware as i am of it
we have to still work hard it's like
pushing a boulder up a hill like
sisyphus to prevent the normalization of
this insanity
we've become somewhat numb to the
reality
that this is what the u.s president does
every day
but we really should not become numb to
it for our own sake
at some point is this sedition
look at the definition sedition is
conduct
or speech inciting people to rebel
against the authority of a state
when donald trump asks brian kemp to
overturn disregard not
count certain ballots specifically
to overturn the will of the people and
change the election results
at what point do we have to call it what
it is i'm not calling it treason
but looking at the definition of
sedition is this not
seditious behavior to some degree there
will never be repercussions
he has seven weeks left and then he's
going to go there will not be
repercussions but we
can't allow this to be mistaken for
anything other than what it is
and the the the casual way
in which so many people now are just
writing all of this office
and trump's tweeting again the country
has never seen anything like this before
and we can't depart from this era
with anything other than the full
understanding that this is outrageous
there is nothing normal about it
and trump's press secretary is
participating in it and i want to talk
about that next so we've had about a
week of silence
from donald trump's press secretary and
campaign advisor yes she's both kaylee
mcinanny she appeared on she resurfaced
last night she appeared on sean
hannity's fox news program
and then again this morning she was on
fox and friends also
on fox news uh kaylee mcinanni
has decided either explicitly or
implicitly
she's going down with the ship she is
not going to be
a rat abandoning the sinking ship
she's going down with the ship and rudy
giuliani by the way has also made this
decision
but this is not a segment about rudy
giuliani now these kayleigh
and nanny clips i'm going to play for
you are extra interesting
because we now know who is going to be
replacing kaylee mcinanni
as joe biden's press secretary it's
going to be jen
sackey and jenn sackey
could not be more different than kaylee
mcinanni jensacki
is a communications professional period
jen sackey was white house
communications director for a couple of
years
during the barack obama administration
she's
merely an adult who behaves like an
adult
and the contrast between the incoming
white house press secretary jen
sackey and the current one kaylee
mcinanny could not be more stark
in terms of just behaving like a normal
person so let's get right into it
here is kaylee mcinanny last night on
sean hannity's program again bringing
props
things to hold up in front of the camera
i believe that
here kaylee mcinanny is appearing at
this interview
as trump campaign advisor now that's
going to be relevant later
she has papers take a look state to
watch this week
is the state of nevada we have been
granted discovery and what that means
in the litigation world is this we are
now allowed to depose
witnesses and notably sean so she holds
up
an order presumably that is the proof
that they've been granted discovery but
look at how the grift
continues and has evolved think back to
what is essentially a month ago a couple
days after the election just under a
month ago
it started with pennsylvania's getting
overturned we won pennsylvania
we're sending corey lewandowski and
jenna ellis or whoever to pennsylvania
this is getting overturned well that
came and went
three weeks ago it was we won georgia
and george is about to flip we are about
to get georgia
for donald trump it didn't happen then
it was listen we won
michigan uh stop the count start the
count whatever michigan we actually won
and we're going to get it
that didn't happen now it's huge
news sean we've been granted
discovery in nevada none of this
is going anywhere period it's a grift
it's the final scam on trump's way out
then kaylee mcinanny goes even further
she moves from holding up at least what
are ostensibly legal documents
although they may be bogus to holding
out a printout of an article
from the blaze website uh who prints out
articles from the internet to hold up on
television my friends take a look at
this
article by daniel horowitz noting that
in pennsylvania
where last time in 2016 one percent of
mail-in ballots were rejected
they get rid of signature match and .038
percent are rejected
okay so that's hannity that's kaylee
mcinanni
senior trump campaign advisor speaking
as a representative of the campaign
about the crazy things the campaign is
doing and claiming now
we go to this morning check out the
metamorphosis it's like an ugly
caterpillar
becoming a majestic butterfly no more
campaign flunky
that was last night under the dark of
night on hannity
this morning we have a phoenix rising
over the horizon
it is kaylee mcinanni white house press
secretary a real government spokesperson
and she is asked by steve ducey kaylee
listen
that stuff you were talking about you
know these lawsuits all this different
stuff
what is the strategy what is the
strategy here
and she says without a shred of irony
listen that's really something the
campaign is involved in
you know i'm i'm white house press
secretary and good for steve ducey he
actually says
yeah but you're both really and she's
not going to answer because this morning
it is not
kaylee trump campaign advisor
with election conspiracies this is
kaylee mcinanni
white house press secretary take a look
and kaylee mcaney she's the white house
press secretary it looks like she's on
the north lawn kayla good morning to you
great to join you good to have you okay
so griff was just talking about
the situation down in georgia where
they've got the twin runoff races first
week in january
and he brought up uh you know the
president is talking about how the
election was rigged
and there are a number of republicans
who are worried that that kind of
thing could backfire on that particular
runoff election because
they say you know if it's rigged if the
if the 2020 november election was rigged
and this one's rigged why should i even
bother voting
yeah you know i'll leave it to the
campaign to pontificate on the
president's strategy with what
sometimes you're with the campaign so
you know the thinking there
i do i'm joining you in my official
capacity today from the white house lawn
but i'll say this the president has been
unapologetic oh my goodness i do
i am part of the campaign sometimes but
today i'm joining you
in my official capacity from the white
house lawn
so it would be inappropriate for me to
comment on things that i myself said
just 12 hours ago
on your very network i can't wait until
she has no official capacity at all
and then she'll become just another
trumpist who lies on television
with no association to the government uh
how is this a thing and my prediction
is if i'm wrong i will i will tell if
the biden people do this i will tell you
it's wrong
my prediction is you're not going to see
jen
sackey joe biden's incoming press
secretary
double as uh biden campaign staff i
don't think you're going to see that and
if you if we do see it i will call it
out
then kaylee again seems to be i guess
trying to give credit for
vaccination research into vaccines at
all to donald trump
using this phrase the president will
never apologize that's a phrase i'll
talk about in a moment
look i think the fda is working around
the clock as well this is a partnership
here
uh everyone wants to see american life
saves from dr stephen hahn
to this president but this president
will never apologize
for putting the fire under these
agencies to say yes we want a safe
vaccine
absolutely we also want to fast one
because lives are at stake
it's also strange because no one wants
trump to apologize
for the fact that medical research
companies
developed vaccines we do think trump
should apologize for lots of other
things which he will never apologize but
they you they love using this phrase the
president this president will never
apologize for it's almost become like a
meme
uh and it never makes any sense it's
actually a pretty good distraction
tactic it's it's actually almost as good
a distraction tactic as kaylee
strategically either being a campaign
advisor
or merely the white house press
secretary as convenient based on what
she does or doesn't want to talk about
but they continually repeat
this president is never going to
apologize and they use it almost like as
a phrase of defiance
and and and principled speech it's
complete nonsense and in fact it should
be a red flag any time you hear
a trump flunky say this president will
never apologize for x y or z
your bs grift radar should be going off
and we'll have more about this
on the show instagram david pakman show
and while you're there follow me on
instagram
at david.pacman we will take a quick
break
and be back right after this the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important
core insights from each book so it's
perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
we are welcoming back to the program
today congressman ro
khanna representing california's 17th
district
located in the heart of silicon valley
uh always great to have you on david
it's always a pleasure
so what what's your big picture takeaway
of the november election joe biden won
the senate
is still a question mark it appears as
though democrats
lost a few seats in the house but will
still will still maintain an advantage
you could
i mean i can psych myself into thinking
the results are great because it's so
difficult to remove an incumbent
president
and we should be glad that we at least
did that and so on
and at the same time absolutely
historically terrible reaction to
coronavirus
should have been an overwhelming
humiliating defeat for donald trump and
it was really pretty close in a few
states i don't know which side is the
right side
well that's probably true to both
obviously it's very hard to defeat an
incumbent
uh biden managed with all of uh
the help of everyone to flip five states
uh
that's the most important task but there
are certain warning lessons
uh in there one i don't think we had a
strong enough
economic message that came through exit
polling showed that
of people who prioritize the economy uh
80 some percent uh voted for trump over
us now i've seen some statistics
which say that oh people who made uh
over a hundred thousand voted for
uh trump and those who made under a
hundred thousand
uh voted for us but that if you break
that down further you see that we do
very very well
uh with those making under a hundred
thousand who are
black or latino we do not do very well
uh with those are making hundred
thousand who are white and who are in
rural communities and in
communities left out and so the
challenge for the party is still how
do we have an economic message or a uh
aspirational message that reaches a lot
of these communities
because until we have house seats in all
of these districts and
an electoral college you're not going to
get progressive change
on medicare for all and free public
college and student debt forgiveness
very hard
if you don't win some of these areas is
a second corona coronavirus stimulus
bill
something that should be i mean it
obviously takes more than a day but
something that joe biden has to start on
on day one
yes i mean i'm hopeful that we can do
something now
before we adjourn the uh the idea i mean
look
here's what i think mcconnell thinks he
thinks the economy will eventually
recover and there's sort of an
indifference to the suffering but there
is this suffering
that is going on i mean people are being
kicked out of their uh
houses of their apartments there don't
have in many cases enough food to eat
and this has already gone on too long as
you remember i was
urging that we come to some deal before
the election that would have been 1.8
1.9 trillion i don't think that offer is
even
going to be in the on the table anymore
but we've got to do something
and certainly if we don't have something
done by the time biden comes
that has to be his top priority you
mentioned
what you think mitch mcconnell is
thinking have any of your republican
colleagues who
are seeing this voter fraud narrative
with bogus lawsuits you know melting
lawyers and all of these different
strange things that we're seeing
have any of them leveled with you and
said listen publicly i'm supporting it
but i don't believe it
and here's why i want to stay in trump's
good graces or like do you have any
insight into what they're thinking
now you know the interesting thing is
that i have as you know relationships
with a number of the republicans that
trump has on for my bills we worked on
yemen but they will not
even in private uh criticize trump
there's such a fear
that that could get out that someone
could say something
that it could get back to trump so i
have never had a
republican colleague even in private on
the house side at least say
uh oh you know what we need to move on
they're they're very very careful
uh very careful what they put in text
very careful what they would say
to a to a colleague when this when the
topic is donald trump
so in terms of the joe biden cabinet
we're learning about more and more of
the picks maybe one of the more
controversial ones is near a tandem for
omb
we're going to talk about that tomorrow
we've seen janet yellen for treasury
which i think is actually very
interesting and she has some really
interesting economic
uh literature and history that she's
participated in over the last 30 years
which has been interesting to look at
the general idea of bernie sanders
elizabeth warren
leaving the senate to be part of the
cabinet aside from
specific positions strategically do you
like it or not like it i think they
they should be part of the government at
least one of them should be just because
you know we forget that bernie sanders
won the first three states i mean i know
beautician got the most delegates but he
got the most votes in iowa new hampshire
nevada he got millions of votes and so
to have that
wing of the party not represented
i think is a a mistake it's a mistake
for joe biden it's a
mistake in terms of the progressive
energy so department of labor is
actually a place he would make a
a big difference i i would support that
and it'll be a challenge if they both
are uh shut out and my understanding is
the vermont governor is committed
to appointing an independent who would
uh caucus with
uh democrats i also think bernie sanders
has earned this i mean
if he wants to continue to to represent
folks in the senate that's his
prerogative but if he feels like he
wants to make an impact in the labor
department i don't see how with his
success and
all he represents why this is even a
fight for him to get this position
so if the position of the biden
transition team were simply
we can't afford to lose them in the
senate that would not satisfy you as an
explanation
no because uh bernie sanders wouldn't
give up the senate and he has uh clearly
gotten a commitment from the republican
governor that they will appoint an
independent there
who will caucus with the democrats so uh
if if they were going to be blunt
and said look we don't want bernie
sanders for x y and z reason i actually
think that would be more honest
my view is that it would be a
mistake not to give bernie sanders
a platform where he thinks he can be
most impactful
bernie sanders thinks he can do that in
the department of labor uh he's earned
that uh
opportunity speaking of leaving the
senate i mean of course we have to
mention that
in your state uh kamala harris is going
to be the vice president of the united
states and so that will be a seat that
opens
i've read a little bit about who the the
sort of
front runners are your name is being
mentioned by many progressives as
someone they would like to see
draft rokana call gavin newsom and say
is that is that a position that would be
interesting to you
sure anyone would be uh honored to to to
represent the state that in the senate
and it would give me a
probably a bigger platform to uh have an
impact on progressive
policies but i believe i can also be
very effective uh
from the house and uh you know the
leading candidate
appears to be padilla my bigger issue is
uh can we get someone who's progressive
who's clearly for medicare for all was
clearly
uh for a 15 minimum wage free public
college and vocational education
for giving student loans and how do we
have bold
policy and there are a number of people
who would fit that bill but that to me
is the most
important yeah what's interesting i like
that you bring that up because
i wanted to talk about what is the
strategy even with a 50 50 senate with
kamala harris as a tiebreak vote
um there are lots of democrats in the
senate
who are not on board with a lot of the
ideas you just talked about and
and so there's actually a real question
i mean things like medicare for all
and and many other ideas like it joe
manchin is not a guaranteed vote on a
lot of those things and when we could go
sort of down the list of some of the
more
centrist right-leaning democratic
senators
is that a concern to you and thinking
about the best-case scenario right now
would be 50-50 with kamala harris as the
tiebreaker
it seems to me that even in that
scenario there are real challenges in
getting some of some of the things we'd
like to see done
actually done david you're absolutely
right and this is where there's a
philosophical difference of what way
the biling administration should go one
theory of the case is
let's solve the pandemic get the vaccine
out
and then there's going to be some
natural recovery
to the economy and let's get whatever we
can get
in either a republican senate or a
divided senate where
everything has to get mansion's vote i
don't think that's sufficient i think
the
better strategy is to say here is our
vision we've got record
income inequality we've got people
who've been left out we need
to have massive public investment in the
creation of new jobs we need to have
massive investment in child care and
education and health care
we're going to pass that in the house
we're going to build public support
we're going to make that case and even
if we're losing votes in the senate
eventually in 22 and 24 and 26 and 28
we're going to get that just society any
great leader in this country
has not overnight brought change they've
built public support we've seen what
bernie did
from 2016 to now so to surrender
the effort at building public support
because it's hard or the numbers aren't
there
i i think is an abdication of political
imagination and political leadership
yeah i mean speaking if we apply a
pragmatic filter to that for a moment
we could imagine a situation where
democrats don't have the senate
um and then the big things that joe
biden campaigned on
which are an expansion of obamacare
public option etc pretty significant
changes to the tax code including
uncapping social security beyond 400k
stepped up basis elimination you know we
look at the full list of the really big
stuff
i'm hearing two things from from
different people on the left oh and we
we just lost your video row i don't know
and you're back there you go that was
weird um so we're hearing two things
from people on the left and right
on the left rather some on the left are
saying you can't comp these republicans
in the senate cannot be compromised with
what you would need to give up as joe
biden
if you don't have the senate to get any
of those things done
would um essentially degrade the quality
of the bill
where joe biden would be giving huge
concessions to the republican party that
are simply not worth doing
the other side is it's worth doing
in order to get anything at all but it
might end up being sort of a pyrrhic
victory do you have a strong feeling one
way or the other about how far
it's worth negotiating with people who
are often negotiating out of such bad
faith
well it depends on the context i mean if
it's a a matter of getting some
unemployment assistance to people and
you're
you know where we can get 300 or 400
dollars instead of 600 dollars i say we
probably have to compromise
to get the relief if we're talking about
expanding medicare if we're talking
about free public college and if we're
talking about student loan forgiveness
and there's really
something token that the republicans are
agreeing to but they're asking for
uh draconian cuts in other programs then
absolutely not
what i would say is let's pass in the
house let's pass
an advocate in the white house at least
biden's policies i mean let's at least
make sure
that that they're passing that i don't
see any justification for joe biden
and nancy pelosi not passing uh every
single thing that
he campaigned on i mean isn't that what
trump did i mean it did trump it was
wrong but
almost he went down his checklist here's
what i campaigned on here's what i'm
going to try to do so
fine and not to do the same thing we
have a democratic house there's no
reason
why we shouldn't have every single thing
that he campaigned on up for a vote and
if we lose the vote
let people know which democrats voted
against it let people know who voted
against the public option
who voted against medicare to 60 who
voted against
uncapping social security uh taxes over
you know raising having taxes on over
four hundred thousand
who voted against uh raising capital
gains taxes
uh over a million dollars there are a
lot of policies
uh that we ought to vote on my fear is
that they're going to say oh
let's have a lowest common denominator
where uh a mansion
or the moderate democrats aren't uh for
it
uh that we're not going to have a vote
and and that's not going to fly
especially given that we
have the house last thing let's talk a
little bit about what's going on with
the virus we
we fortunately appear to be just a
couple of weeks
from the first vaccines starting to the
first doses of the first vaccine
starting to get to people december 8 to
10 there's going to be this meeting to
look at least at the pfizer
emergency use authorization shortly
thereafter the moderna one
we're told within 24 to 48 hours of that
which could be december 11th 12th 13th
the first doses are going to start going
into people's
arms there's two things that are sort of
going on here one
is the initially limited supply of these
vaccines where
you can hopefully best case inoculate
20 million people a month that's going
to take a while before we get to
to some level of herd immunity the other
side is
40 of the country still says they're not
really interested in getting a vaccine
which will make it very difficult to
ever get to that hurt immunity
what are you and your colleagues looking
at and thinking about in terms of the
vaccination program
yeah there was an interesting idea
actually by john delaney who sent it to
the op-ed to me that he says that we
ought to be linking a 1500
stimulus or payment to getting the
vaccine now i haven't looked at all the
constitutionality or ethics around it
but i think having some sort of
incentive system
to get vaccine adoption
should be on the table but at the very
least we need uh
massive funding on uh on outreach and
figuring out uh how we incentivize
hospitals uh
to get that get it distributed but i
think it is it's going to be a great a
challenge i mean i've
heard you got to get to about 60 70
percent uh vaccination
uh and and that's uh going to be the
administrative challenge now i will say
this about ron klein he's
uh exceedingly competent and uh whatever
else you think about
the ban administration i do think he
will
manage this process uh well yeah i mean
the crazy thing is initially none of
these vaccines will be given to children
and once you remove
children from the 330 million population
you actually need close to a hundred
percent of
adults to get to that 70 percent and i
don't think that that that is
necessarily being taken
taken seriously that's interesting i
didn't even i hadn't even thought about
that
uh point and uh it's a good point i mean
look they
they're they're this is where i think
that the binding administration is i
mean they're going to be judged in the
first six months to nine months
on the administrative uh roll out of
this vaccine and i'm sure in the back of
their minds is that
when the affordable care act happened it
was botched the
the roll out and that really hurt uh
people and it hurt the
public perception so they're right to be
focused uh
on uh that administration but there's a
dual crisis there's that
problem and then there's an economic
crisis and
then there's a structural crisis that
elizabeth warren and bernie sanders
spoke to
about in my view is we we can't ignore
both the structural crisis and the
immediate crisis economically
and we have to pay attention to that
substantively and for political reasons
do you like the idea of airlines concert
venues etc saying
after a certain date if you want to come
to an event or fly with us
you must be vaccinated yes i think that
that's a
a very reasonable position and uh and
and probably constitutional i mean my
sense is that you are required to have
vaccinations to go to school
for example so uh the uh
being in public places uh it makes sense
you know i was talking to a
because i represent silicon nelly one of
the privileges i get to talk to some of
these leading technologists and
scientists and
i was talking to someone yesterday who
said that if we put the resources
there's no reason
we couldn't have vaccine detectors like
smoke detectors which could literally
detect almost any vaccine in a room and
we put so much money in our military so
that we could detect the smallest
threat to our country militarily i don't
understand why we're not putting in the
resources now to be detecting
uh pandemics and future pandemics that
is interesting that is not one i had
heard but i
i will certainly uh look into that we've
been speaking with congressman ro
khanna representing california's 17th
district
always a pleasure having you on david
thank you for having me
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
this next story is both really funny and
also really tragic because lots of
people get their so-called news
from sean hannity on fox news last night
on his program sean hannity sort of
haphazardly and indirectly admitted that
he doesn't vet
the information that he gives out on the
show now he was trying to make the case
that he's so independent that he doesn't
check with other people he doesn't
need anybody's permission to say
whatever the hell he wants on his
program nobody
is telling him what stories to cover and
not to cover
but what he actually ended up admitting
is that he doesn't even necessarily know
whether what he's telling you is
accurate he doesn't necessarily know
if what he's telling you is true which
is actually
not unique to sean hannity's program as
far as fox opinion programs are
concerned
but i'm going to get back to that and it
relates to a lawsuit involving tucker
carlson from a few months ago
but let's set it up here is a clip of a
defiant and principled sean hannity
telling you
he might be giving you false information
regularly
on his program take a look we in this
hour
i am not told what to say i don't vet
the information on this program that i
give out
we have always been independent follow
our own path on this show
that's not going to change for me ever
if you thought
that it might change this will not
change ever says sean hannity now
of course anybody who understands and
pays attention to fox news
with a critical eye knows this i mean
just in the past few months
sean hannity notably promoted bogus
coronavirus treatments and cures
he promoted and regularly promotes voter
fraud conspiracy
theories related to the election
including that donald trump won this
state that state the other state
none of which there's a speck of
evidence for
but the problem is that lots of
hannity's viewers don't realize that
this is merely an opinion show
and one we've now learned thanks to sean
hannity admitting it
it's one where hannity doesn't even vet
the things that he puts out on the air
but here's what i want to remind you
this is really the important thing in an
effort to sort of build an understanding
of media literacy
this is not actually unique to hannity
this is not about sean hannity per se
back in september we covered this on the
bonus show
fox news's own lawyers said in court
that the audience shouldn't believe
that what tucker carlson says on his
program is facts
there was a case against tucker carlson
for slander in the southern district of
new york
and in the opinion from the judge there
were quotes
from fox news's lawyers made in the case
and the defense that fox news lawyers
put forward
was that anyone who watches tucker
carlson's show
should just be able to tell from what
they referred to as the general tenor of
the program
that tucker carlson is not quote stating
actual facts
on his program and that what tucker
carlson is doing this is
lawyers for fox news saying tucker
should not be held to that standard
because tucker uses exaggeration
and non-literal commentary this is the
evil genius of this
you have an entire political movement in
this country
that has been taught molded and
conditioned
to take their political agenda from fox
news
if fox news says cancel culture is the
issue then that's the issue and you
spread it around if fox news says the
issue is
you know trump really won or whatever
that that becomes the issue and in
particular
they get this agenda from the nighttime
opinion shows on fox news
of which you know we're including uh
sean hannity tucker carlson laura ingram
janine pirro on the weekends
um you know lou dobbs i think is fox
business uh
mark levin all of these people we all
know
that these are merely bogus opinion
shows that are meant to fire up and
radicalize and anger the base which
works
and then you see fox news successfully
set the agenda
that pervades politics around the
country for the american right wing
but when the rubber hits the road and
these hosts start getting sued for
slander
or they have other legal issues because
of false statements they've made
the lawyers show up and they don't even
hesitate they immediately go to anybody
should be able to tell these are not
facts being presented
this is entertainment it's non-literal
commentary and
it's it's actually what alex jones's
lawyers also argued in
i don't remember if it was a some kind
of libel or slander
suit or maybe his divorce proceedings i
don't even remember
but his lawyers essentially said you you
can't you can't litigate anything that's
set on the show because it's and it's
entertainment it's just a character
that alex jones is playing that's
exactly the problem though which is that
fox news's business model has been let's
dress up radical conspiracies and wild
speculation
that would not normally be on national
cable tv
but let's produce it in a way that it
looks like real news
and when you flip around and importantly
fox news on the
cable dial often is right next to actual
news networks
people flip around and they see it and
it's like you know
looks like news the anchors talk like
this is news
i guess this is news and people fall for
it so
where they say in the lawsuit defending
uh
in the defense against the lawsuit
against tucker carlson when the fox news
lawyers say
any viewer should be able to tell this
is not factual news where we present
facts
that's true but their very business
model has depended on
looking like real news so that when
people see it they think they're
watching news
part of it is a media literacy issue
it's an education issue for sure
but part of the problem is that fox news
is participating
in being deliberately confusing about
exactly what they are putting out they
blend
the news and opinion we've talked about
that before but they
also present opinion shows as
if they are serious programs rather than
mere
entertainment and what it leads to is an
audience that when they don't get what
they want on fox
they end up being radicalized over to
networks like newsmax and oan
and that's exactly what i want to talk
about next this
story is almost beyond belief except
if you've been paying attention the last
four years you won't be
that surprised by it as you might know
donald trump and trump cultists
are increasingly mad at fox news
because anecdotally some fox news
anchors
have acknowledged and recognized that
joe biden won the election
trump has increasingly as a result been
pushing people to instead watch
oan and newsmax which are even crazier
channels
than fox news oan reported a completely
laughable conspiracy theory alleging
that because
one stream of joe biden's thanksgiving
address
had only a thousand live concurrent
viewers
clearly 80 million people couldn't
possibly have voted for joe biden
in the election a month ago now you
might hear that reasoning and you might
say
that that's spurious how do these things
even relate and that would be the
correct reaction
but one person who found it at least
crowd credible enough to tweet
was donald trump himself who tweeted
quote report
biden's thanksgiving day address gets
just over a thousand
views online which is not even true by
the way a record low
observers say and what he means is a guy
on twitter
observers say a candidate with 80
million votes
would get many more online viewers
numbers don't lie
or add up o-a-n
so here is the report from oan
that the president is referring to check
out this absurd i mean to even call it a
report i'm really stretching the
definition of a report but take a look
at it
joe biden stirs a new controversy after
his thanksgiving address
fails to attract viewers reports
thursday found biden's live stream
address
got only 1 000 views online the former
vice president delivered
a teleprompter address on wednesday in
another baseless attempt to pose as the
winner of the recent elections
the mainstream media portrays biden as
the most popular candidate in history of
u.s politics
giving him 80 million votes however
observers say biden's miserable
viewership online does not reflect his
purported popularity
that is the channel that trump is now
promoting over fox news
this entire thing is just horrifying in
terms of
what it means for the country now i
could sit here and fact check right like
i could say
well listen it was a thousand live
concurrents
not a thousand views and that was on one
stream on twitter
and if you look at different networks
and youtube streams and tv
there were actually millions of live
viewers but that would be a waste of
time
the people who have decided that joe
biden stole the election
don't care the point is they will seek
out anyone
who will keep telling them what they
want to hear that during
some hours of the day is no longer fox
news which acknowledges biden 1 so
during the day
when fox has people who say well the
president did lose
they'd go to newsmax they go to oan and
oan is quite literally quoting some guy
on twitter about this so-called theory
the real story here is how this goes
back to what we talked about
earlier this week which is that fox news
and trump
within his fake news meme have so
radicalized the right
that they just reject anything that is
reality-based media if it's not what
they want to believe and they look
elsewhere
the followers are now too radical for
fox news if you can imagine something so
scary
and the truth doesn't matter you can
look around like i said
the nbc stream of the joe biden
thanksgiving address had half a million
views
the joe biden youtube channel stream had
a hundred thousand abc 125 000 cbs 100
000.
the tv networks that covered it it's not
about that
why are we even still talking about
biden's low ratings as
trump liked to talk about them during
the campaign the entire
framework is online popularity
should help us figure out who should be
president trump's rally size
his twitter followers are indicative
of trump being a better choice for
president the fact that people
believe that paradigm is part of the
problem and that's unlikely to change
anytime soon
it's really the appeal to popularity you
know sometimes i get emails or messages
from people saying david
your channel is terrible and you're
lying
and you are losing viewers and the truth
is the channel has grown
every month from the last decade we were
the top left-wing independent
youtube channel for live streams of the
rnc dnc debates election day
we're close to 1.2 million subscribers
more than we've ever had
we've added 92 000 subscribers in the
last four weeks
but even arguing with them is almost
like participating in the appeal to
popularity
we might have those numbers and be a
terrible channel or not
just because something generates
eyeballs doesn't mean it's necessarily
good
and that's very much the case here even
if their assertions
about joe biden's you know views on a
thanksgiving day address
it tells us nothing about who won the
election and it tells us nothing about
who's the better choice for president
but
until there's a paradigm shift and these
things are rethought uh we're not going
to get out of this
sort of death spiral of incompetence and
uh it's going to take more than just
replacing trump with biden to solve that
problem it's a much bigger issue
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
this is a caller this is our biblical
prophecy caller
she's called in many times over the
years and she analogizes
the news into biblical prophecy in a way
that for me is
completely disconnected from reality and
uh
irrelevant but it's still interesting
apparently biden defeating trump
has thrown biblical prophecy into chaos
take a listen to this
i i have bad news for you um i felt for
a long time
that uh bush was the right around the
fiery red horse obama was right around
the dark wars
right in revelations apocalypse four
horsemen
chapter six and that trump is the writer
on the pale horse
and because he lost the election hades
follows close behind
yetis is biden i think he wants a war
against israel
um because he ran with obama
and so he would be pro is a a
pro uh islam and um
uh i think he's gonna kill christians
and hunger and peace
and death covet and something else that
i can't remember
yeah so whatever that that goes on for
two more minutes so so that listen i
mean that that's a framework that's a
framework and i know that it's easy to
laugh it off but that's a framework that
actually
appeals to a lot of people in the united
states seeing things through that lens i
think it's
completely counterproductive beyond just
not being based in fact but i do
for some reason i find it fast like i
find that call fascinating i think
the pale horse and killing christians
i i am fascinated that that is a
framework that some people find uh
find reasonable but you know to each
their own as i say
uh let's remind you that we have a
tremendous bonus bonus show
oh boy we have a tremendous bonus
show for you today we will talk about a
trump donor wanting his money back
and much much more get instant access to
the i have to be careful here
bonus show by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
if you're trying to quit smoking or
vaping check out lucy which is a
nicotine gum developed by caltech
scientists they'll ship it right to your
door and you can save
twenty percent when you go to lucy.co
and use coupon code pacman blinkist is
the app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman